- Hey, guys, here in Stockholm
With my homie from Arctic Startup, John.
Going to the airport
and heading back to NYC.
But in this video, I was
actually in Hong Kong doing Q&A.
Some really interesting insights,
some different stuff was
pulled out of me and so
I hope you enjoy it and
just wanna thank all
of you for following me
on all of the platforms and
if you haven't subscribed yet
to the Youtube and are
just stumbling here,
or continue watching it,
but aren't subscribed,
I'd love that and hope you
guys are doing super well.
See ya, much love.
(jazzy downtempo music)
- Please welcome, the
social juggernaut himself,
Mr, Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Man] And no introduction for me.
- I did it...
(laughing)
- Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
(whoops)
There's a big crowd.
Gary V.
Thank you very much for
coming, really appreciate it.
- Thanks for having me.
- This is incredible because
as Brendan mentioned,
I've been working on this
for the past six months,
actually met your team in New York City
and we jammed a little
bit, so it was amazing,
but I don't wanna spend
too much time on this,
I really wanna give people
a chance to ask you
some questions later on,
but I wanna set some
context for that, because
I dunno, probably there are some people
that don't know you so much, so
the first thing I wanna talk about.
I watched the interview
that you did with Tom from Impact Theory
and he did incredible job.
- Yeah, he did.
- And one thing that I really enjoyed
was the 51/49 Karma and Practicality
and all of these things, could
you just talk about that?
Like being a nice person,
bringing value first,
what it means for you and then we can
go deeper, how other
people should manage it
when they're just getting started,
because I think that's super
relevant for these guys,
'cause we're just getting started.
We're not so big as you are,
but we should provide
even more value probably,
but also we need to focus
on the business, right?
Business side and building it,
so could you just talk
about it a little bit?
- Sure, first of all, thank
you guys all so much for coming
it's awesome to be here.
(applause)
Yeah, I think Karma is practical.
I'm confused by people's
inability to understand
how human beings work and
I think that a lot of
the reason that startups
are gonna fail at a record rate,
which is exactly what's gonna happen
over the next decade, is that
so many people in this room
are gonna build their business
in the eyes of a VC not
in the eyes of the market.
All of their behavior will be
predicated on raising capital,
not on bringing value.
You know, at it's core,
the reason I'm answering
this question that way is,
you have to reverse
engineer what you want.
The greater your ambition for legacy
and something meaningful, the
greater you are as a person
'cause it's really the only practical way
to actually pull it off.
You have to provide more value
than you asked for in return.
And so for me, all I wanna do is,
I think about being entrepreneur
like being an athlete.
I think about my life when
I don't have my jersey on,
and I think about my life
when I have my jersey on.
And when I'm an entrepreneur,
when I put on my jersey in the morning,
there's two main goals in my mind.
One, to build the greatest
legacy of being an entrepreneur,
what I would consider getting
into the hall of fame,
and two, that's my macro.
And my micro is to be
successful that day, right?
It's a day in, day out thing, so yeah.
My thesis is that I need to
bring more value in my content,
I need to bring more
value to my employees,
I need to bring more value to my clients,
I prefer the leverage of
being more valuable to you
than you are to me.
It's actually quite practical.
If I'm more valuable to
you than you are to me,
that ultimately should
work itself out for me
in the long term, and
I only play long term.
Like really, really long term.
Like, the end.
(laughing)
And I don't think most people do,
I am so grateful that I'm wired
and parented in a way where,
when I was making $50,000
a year, that was...
I'm gonna say something that confuses me,
I just think $50,000
a year is enough money
to live your life, I dunno.
It's not enough if you
wanna have a fuckin' yacht
in the fucking water out there,
but I have not been driven
by capital and money
pretty much ever.
You know, look at my
actions versus my words,
I built my family's business
to a much bigger business
than it was.
I entered my dad's business, it was doing
three-point-something
million dollars in sales,
I left it as a business that
was doing $60 million in sales,
I own zero percent of WineLibrary.
Zero, I then started, on
the back of what I was doing
as a marketer, a new
company called VaynerMedia,
my brother AJ was graduating from college,
he was no experience, no
equity in the marketplace,
we started VaynerMedia and
that company was 50/50.
I just am not driven by economics
and that's fine, 'cause, by the way,
if you are, great.
It's just that I give more than I receive
because it's the game
I'm actually playing.
And you have to decide your game,
if your game is predicated
on you wanna own
a yacht and a nice home and a gold watch,
then that's fine, then
you should care about
short term economics.
But short term economic
strategies leave you vulnerable.
- You know what I love about you?
That you actually care about people
and there are two stories, so first,
I don't know if you remember,
but first time we met
was actually in Lisbon,
so I was waiting for you
at the speaker prep
and I just wanted to have the book signed
and you arrived late, the
bodyguards were pushing,
you cannot go in, and
I told you "Hey, Gary,
"I'm a big fan, I just
want this book signed."
And you said, "Oh, I'm sorry,
I'm speaking in five minutes,"
but you went in, you just
put your luggage there,
and then you came out and signed my book.
And the same thing
happened, I have a friend,
he's over there, so I was
sitting with him yesterday,
and he took a selfie with you at Rice,
and then he tweeted it,
and you liked his tweet.
And he was going crazy about it, you know.
He was like, Ahhhh, you know.
(cheering from crowd)
So I love this about you that
you actually spend the time,
now we are in a Tesla, we are driving here
and you are just tweeting
and checking Instagram,
and you're just doing it all the time,
the work ethic, you know,
you're just online all the time.
- If you were privileged enough for people
to actually care that you like a Tweet?
Then you need to take that responsibility
and do something with it, like
I will never take for granted
like guys, I have been somebody
who loved entrepreneurship
and I didn't call it entrepreneurship,
I'm old I'm 41, I called it
being a businessman, right?
This was everything and
anything I ever wanted to do.
If you thought, at any
time, in my teenage years,
that I thought that being
a successful entrepreneur
would lead to people treating
you like a successful athlete
or rockstar, there was
no part of the vision
that that was gonna be any part of it.
So the added value of admiration,
is such a cherry on top,
it's why I push people
to do the thing they love the most.
You don't know how the
world's gonna play out.
All my friends who are such
unbelievable video game players
in the 90s, whose parents made
them stop playing video games
to be a lawyer, none of us
knew that e-sports was coming.
They could've been the Tony Hawk,
right?
Like, you don't know
where the world's going.
Too many people make decisions
on how the world is today
and they're making decisions
about 14 years from now
as if the world will stay still.
So I can't wrap my head
around taking for granted
people thinking I'm cool
and I will work hard
to show my gratitude
for the rest of my life.
- Yeah, but also it's
amazing business strategy,
because we were just
talking in the car about
Jake Paul and Logan and
they're just building an empire
just by doing YouTube videos
and engaging their fans
and basically just like
showing them the love.
So it's amazing business
strategy at the same time,
- Yeah, but it's only a nuance.
You can't show people love
unless you did something
that made them like
you in the first place.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So what Jake
and Logan Paul are, are
incredible programmers
and producers and content
producers for a new environment,
no different than Steven
Spielberg and George Lucas were
for the theater environment
of the late 70s.
I think we underestimate
what it takes to be a KOL
in today's environment, we
think it's easy for some reason,
'cause it feels so remarkable
that if you're cute, or funny,
like it just feels weird, right?
Like oh my god,
you're just charismatic
or have a nice smile
or a great figure and now all of a sudden
you're making a lot of money.
The reality is being
pretty always made money,
it was called modeling.
(chuckling)
Being funny always made money,
you just did it on stage,
that's what Richard Prior
and Eddie Murphy did and now,
King Batch might just do
it on Vine or Instagram.
Nothing's new, the mediums are new.
Do not have the audacity to underestimate
what it takes to have enough
success that a lot of people
pay attention to you.
Do not underestimate that.
You're thrilled to, but the
market is smarter than you.
- [Jan] Awesome, and now,
we are in Hong Kong, right?
This is your first time.
- Yes.
- [Jan] This is your
first time in Hong Kong.
- Yes.
- How do you like it?
- You know, it's funny, Drock and I landed
and we didn't even leave baggage claim,
that's 5:04 in the morning,
we're in baggage claim.
And I looked at him and I go,
I think I'm gonna fuckin' love this place.
(laughing)
It's been an unbelievable trip,
I texted my wife and said
we're moving to Hong Kong.
(laughing)
(cheering and applause)
I'm not moving to Hong Kong.
I'm not moving to Hong Kong, but
I see a lot of familiar
faces, there are people here
who do know me.
I need action.
Hong Kong has action, so it's interesting.
- Well I guess China has action, too.
And so because on your daily
feed, sending your content,
you have been pushing China quite a bit.
- I've been alluding to some ambitions.
- One of the latest daily
piece, or not latest,
because you do it every day, but,
you were in Cannes and you said
you're gonna dominate
China in three years,
so tell me, why China?
Why do you care about China right now
and what's the strategy that
you're executing against
right now.
- I don't know if you heard,
but there's a lot of people there.
(laughing)
One thing,
again, something that I
think some of you have heard,
I don't like talking about things
that I don't know and I
don't have the audacity
to think that my brand or my
businesses could be successful
in China until I'm very
thoughtful and committed
to giving that a chance.
And so, I'm starting to feel
good about the infrastructure
of the Vayner Machine in a US standpoint,
in a European standpoint, and
to be very frank,
intuitively, intuitively,
I just feel like it's time for Asia.
Which is why I said yes to Rise,
which is why I said yes
to the event I'm doing
in Singapore in October.
I've never, not only have
I never been to Hong Kong,
I've never been to Asia,
prior to this trip.
I've been to India,
I've been to Australia,
depending on how you
want to define things,
but I've not been to
this part of the world
and ironically,
the purity of entrepreneurship, and
maybe purity is not the
right word, the rawness
of the entrepreneurship in
Asia is far more aligned with
my rawness of entrepreneurship
than the US or Europe,
so I think it's gonna
be very native to me,
I'm excited about it, I think
I have a humongous advantage
in being born in Soviet Russia, so I come
with a lot of humility, of the
amount of work and listening
I'm gonna have to do over
the next two to three years.
I like challenging myself,
I feel like I'm one of
the only people on earth
that can literally amass
billions of dollars
and still be deemed a failure
if I don't buy the jets.
(laughing)
You know.
So when i shift, like
I'm gonna dominate China
in three years, that's to motivate me.
That's me playing my own game for myself,
I think I won't be doing anything close
to dominating China
over the next two years,
even though I'm gonna
put in a lot of work,
and then I think I'm gonna understand
and I'm gonna turn it on.
And I do think in a three
year macro, five year macro,
I'll have some success.
Because I think it's intuitive and native
and very aligned with my spirit.
And I also think the youth,
the entrepreneurial youth
of China, both on patience
and on their relationship
with their parents, are
gonna get a lot of value
out of my content.
- Awesome.
And actually, I just
wanna follow up on this,
because you said you don't
like to talk about things
that you don't understand,
but this morning,
we are having breakfast and you,
actually, lunch, after lunch,
and you actually know a lot of things
about China in terms of
where the KOL industry is
and this, how do you do this?
Do you have people in your
team that are doing it for you
and then you just analyze,
or do you actually read something?
How do you absorb this information,
because you're so busy
running around the world
speaking and doing business,
so how do you manage this?
- So Drock, right before,
right when I got off
the stage right now
back at the conference,
said to me, it's been really cool for him
to watch me navigate here
over the last two days.
He asked me, did you
read anything about...?
The market, and I said no.
And I think he intuitively understood that
that was gonna be the answer.
Listen, the one thing I think,
so I think if you know who I am.
If I say to you the word hustle,
that seems very natural,
you know I care about that,
I talk about that.
If I say the word to you, smart,
that feels foreign, because
I never speak about it.
I rarely, if ever,
talk about how smart I am, I mean that.
And the reason I don't talk about it,
is 'cause I don't think that
that brings you any value.
You know, I think making
you realize that work ethic
is a variable that is
far more controllable
than almost anything else
that is a direct indicator
on your success is a
valuable conversation.
I think me telling you that
the answer to your question is
that I absorb information
so quickly and synthesize
it through a filter
that is so intuitive, that
I'm successful at marketing
and communications is
cool for me, for myself,
and I'm happy about it,
but not something I speak to.
I think,
I understand human beings,
period, end of story.
And I understand and I respect
cultural differences and nuances,
but no matter what, communist
Russia, communist China,
capitalistic America, capitalistic London.
We all have our cultures,
but there are so many things
that are tried and true human
no matter where you are.
And I trade on those things.
And it doesn't take you long to realize,
I had never heard the term KOL
36 hours ago.
(laughing)
I call it influencers.
- Yeah.
- But if you call it KOL,
then I'll call it KOL.
These are semantics.
Influencer marketing is
influencer marketing,
I wanna remind everybody here
that I started a Vine agency
four months after Vine came out
that every person you know, globally,
outside of China influencers,
I've touched or knew
before they blew up.
Like my contest picked Logan
Paul to be the next Vine star.
Like I've been in this.
I was an influencer on YouTube in 2006,
I was an influencer on Twitter in 2007.
These things are tried and true,
I'm very good at pattern recognition.
I'm very good at human psychology,
and I'm extremely good at
humility in the early stages
when you have to understand the nuances.
- Amazing, so, guys.
Because we wanna provide some value here,
some questions.
Who has a question for Gary?
Is there any question?
- Yeah, here.
- [Man] How many hours
a night do you sleep?
Do you track your sleep
or anything like that?
- I don't track my sleep.
I invested in a company called
Wakemate, which was an early
tracker technology back
in the day, like 2009.
But their first hardware like
combusted into flames randomly
and so they went out of business.
But that was the only time I was close
to ever tracking my sleep.
I sleep six hours a night.
I try, I'll sleep more, fuck,
I wish I could sleep all
the time, to be very...
(laughing)
I hate
the idea that people think
that I'm against sleeping
or that sleeping is not cool.
Sleeping is fucking important.
I am far more passionate
about what you're doing
when you're awake than
I am when you sleep.
I'm not worried if you
sleep eight hours a day,
I'm worried that you're
fucking around the other 16.
So
I think the sleep conversation needs to be
talked about more and
defined, and I've been very...
It's a great first question.
I'm curious, and by the
way, I'm only curious
about what you're doing 16 hours a day
when your mouth is ahead of your actions.
If you're telling me you're gonna build
a hundred million dollar company,
and you have any leisure, I'm
calling you out on bullshit.
It's hard enough to build
a million dollar business.
You know one that's actually profitable.
So, I try to sleep six, seven.
But I get plenty of fours
and fives, they happen.
But I'd prefer not.
I mean, one of the biggest
reasons I think I wanna spend
more time in Asia is
these fuckin' 16 hour flights,
I can get a nice 8-9-10.
(laughing)
And still get work done.
- Yeah.
- I was like,
this was literally the
happiest day of my year so far
was the 16 hour flight here.
I hadn't been sleeping
much, 'cause of serendipity,
so I slept 10, Cathay has no WiFi,
so I wasn't distracted and ADD'd out,
so I had 6 hours of work,
got my inbox to zero
for the first time in
five and a half months.
I fuckin' land, fuckin' rested as shit,
inbox zero, I'm like, fuck yeah.
(laughing)
- 'Nother question here.
- [Man] Cool, thank you, so we know
a ton about a lot of your successes,
I was curious to know,
can you walk us through
one of your biggest failures
and what you learned from that.
- I think, you know look,
I've only run two businesses in my life
and they're both gonna end up being
pretty fuckin' successful.
I think my failures are the
things that I didn't do.
Like, I don't think anything I operate
is gonna fail, because I
don't have failure behavior.
I'm patient and slow,
so I'm not overextending myself.
I'm not driven by short term capital,
I have skill, and was
making $4,000 a weekend
when I was 12 years old
selling baseball cards.
So I'm a naturally good business salesman.
I know how to run my shit,
I don't care about what
anybody thinks about me,
so I never do behavior that postures
ahead of what I can afford.
So I don't have behavior
for operational failure.
I think my failures are
in all the opportunities
that I had, I'm crippled by opportunity.
Every single day I get
three to four emails
that are batshit crazy, right,
do this, do that.
Take 50% of my company this,
become the face of this TV show,
open this office, I'll
give you my business.
Buy this business, I'm
crippled by opportunity,
I'm saying no so much,
so many of those things
should have been yeses, so,
yeah, I mean, like Travis, right.
Travis is the only person I
reference in my first book
besides my family, yet I
pass on Uber's angel round
of four million dollar evaluation, twice,
my normal $25-50,000 check.
You're talking about two to eight
hundred million dollar return.
That's a failure.
You know, but I don't
it's crazy, right, that's
game changing, right?
I don't know your psyche,
but saying no twice
in a time when you were
saying yes to a ton of shit,
and you said no to one of
your best friends, twice,
and it turned out to be one
of the biggest companies
of all time,
I mean, I dunno, maybe it's like
I might have pulled off one
of the biggest failures ever.
(laughing)
I just don't even think about it that way,
it's just the cost of entry,
it's part of the sport.
I don't dwell on it.
I probably have so many more failures,
I'm just incapable of synthesizing them.
The level of disrespect
I have for my failures
is overwhelming, I believe
way too many people here
respect the shit out of their failures.
Fuck your failures.
Everybody else is judging your failures.
(chuckling)
- Is there any way that
you can train this?
Like that you don't
care about your failures
and that you let somebody down?
- I think it's predicated on self esteem
and genuine love for what you're doing
and so I don't know if that's teachable.
But I do think there's a framework.
If you asked me why my
answer was just that,
it's that I love losing
as much as I love winning,
because I love the game.
And they both are equally, like Uber,
I think you've got a read on this.
Like, I love it, so I talk about it.
- Yeah.
- I love it.
I fuckin' love it.
And so I think that's one,
and then I think self esteem.
I'm confident in a macro
that I'll make it up.
My vulnerability is being
very bitter in my elder years
when I don't have as much time.
I'm so happy to be doing
this that when I know
that I get to do this
for another 45 years,
it's hard for me to be upset
about something that happened
five minutes ago, or last
year, or seven years ago.
What I'm worried about, my
kryptonite is being 83, 87
and knowing there's just
not 20 years to go, right?
And so that will be
something that I worry about.
To be very frank with you,
I'm optimistic that I'll
sell myself on some other
fruits, grandchildren,
who knows what, but it is
something that I think about.
Which is, I'm just so
optimistic, and it's predicated
on just more time and time will go away.
- You are, because this morning, we had
a little bit of mix up in the morning
and I was kind of upset, you know, because
you're a busy guy and I thought,
like, I'm wasting your time
if I'm not going to
deliver exactly the thing
that we agreed on, but you told me like,
no, you didn't waste my time
and we talked about some different stuff.
But like, for me it was
like that experience
that I cared so much about you
and not letting you down...
- So look, I think money
and success expose people.
I don't think it changes them.
So
yeah, you had some other
people that were supposed
to join our meeting this morning,
they didn't show up, I don't think my time
is so much more valuable than yours.
I just don't.
So I did what I believe in the most,
which is I adjusted to the situation.
'Cause people didn't show up
and we did some other shit.
(laughing)
You know, like I just think
the people that would make
you feel bad about that, and by the way,
plenty of important, big
people make you feel bad
about that.
I just think they're fuckfaces.
You know.
- I love you.
- I just think they're imposing
their insecurities on you,
when they make you feel bad about that.
- Awesome, you have a question here.
And then.
- Hey, Gary.
- Come here, come here.
- Name tag.
- [Woman] Name tag.
- I'm not that good.
Hello, Madison.
- Thank you for coming to Hong
Kong and sharing your time
with us, great to have you.
You touched a little bit on intelligence,
of course it's not what
you really wanna focus on,
evangelizing work ethic and hustle.
But what about purpose,
because you found the trifecta
of harnessing your
intelligence, doing the grind,
but for people that are still
trying to find that purpose,
so that it's really mission oriented,
so they can sustain themselves,
what can you tell us
about finding your purpose.
- I think you need to try to
go insular and taste things.
Purpose is a fancy word for happiness.
I think if you break it down,
purpose, what's my purpose, what's my why?
My homie Simon, right,
yeah, it's semantics.
Like for me,
I can't stress enough, you have to, again,
and I'm gonna keep hounding this,
'cause I need you to understand.
When I was five, I thought it was,
when I was seven, when I was nine,
on a summer day, I'm a kid of the 80s,
in America, which means you
went outside and you played,
right?
I thought it was more fun
to convince, manipulate,
whatever semantic word
you wanna use, my friends
into standing behind lemonade stands
or ringing people's doorbells
and washing their cars.
Like, it's my true love, right?
And I don't think most
people want to follow
their true love, 'cause a, my true love
was building a business that makes money.
Which is very practical.
I think if somebody's true love is music,
they haven't figured out
how to make it monetizable
because they have friction.
'Cause their true love is something
but they also want money.
And stuff,
and I think that people waver.
I think people struggle to find purpose
because they overvalue things
and people's opinions over
their own true happiness.
It's as basic as it gets.
So I think that people,
I think everybody here
if I told them, everything
is gonna be okay,
you can have everything you want.
Now, what are you gonna do with your day?
I think a lot of people know.
It could be anything.
If you were to then watch movies all day,
if we played this game,
and you're like okay,
everything?
Well, fuck, I don't wanna do shit,
I just wanna watch movies.
Cool, I think you should
build a business around that.
Like to me, great, right?
So I think people are scared.
I think people are scared,
I think they're scared
what people will think,
and I think they're scared
that they can't survive
living the life that they wanna live
from a materialistic standpoint.
What makes me so dangerous,
is I don't need anything.
I don't need anything,
I don't need anybody,
and that's it, and so I'm good.
And I wish that on everybody.
You know how nice it is
to not rely on anybody
for anything at all ever, not emotionally,
not financially, it's just the Zen zone.
But purpose is to make yourself happy.
I'm a nice guy, 'cause I like admiration.
And so I have to give it.
That's my purpose, but it's all predicated
on making me happy.
I'm nice
because it makes me feel good
what they say about me.
Like, you have to
understand, it's very basic.
And so,
yeah, I think people are scared.
I, listen, if I could ever convince you
that you don't need shit, you
would be off to the races.
If you could unmaterialistic yourself,
you'd be fucking, fuck, you know?
- Over there, little girl.
- I've been working on a startup myself
and despite everyone being really nice,
I've always noticed that
there's sort of like,
you're a bit too young to do this.
How do you get past the
stereotypes or limitations?
- I think you know the answer, Hillary,
I think it's in your own head, right?
Like, the bottom line is,
do you agree with that?
Great, you're on your fuckin' way.
Right, like,
listen, is your mom here?
There she is, like,
you've already won, right.
Your question, do you wanna hear
something interesting, Hillary?
I don't think you even
believe in the question
that you just asked me.
And that is the ultimate compliment,
because spending time with
you backstage yesterday,
like, I think that's a cute question,
but I actually don't
think you give a shit.
(chuckling)
Do you give a shit
about what people think.
- Occasionally.
- Right.
I respect that.
(laughing)
Hillary,
(applause)
I'm gonna tell you
something really exciting,
you're 12, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so
I'm gonna tell you
something super exciting.
When I was 12, I occasionally
cared what people thought too.
that shit goes away real quick.
(laughing)
That's the answer, like, what.
Like, what?
Your teacher or your
uncle Rick fuckin' thinks
that you're too early?
Like, it's just not gonna
matter at the end, Hillary.
Here's what's gonna happen,
either you're right or they're right.
That's what's gonna happen at the end.
Spending any time debating
who's cheering for what outcome
or what point of view is a
complete waste of your energy.
- So we have maybe, we have
time for like two more,
quick ones, so.
- So we have 30 on the back
end for books, like that?
- Yeah, because we have...
- Let's do 20 of that,
let's do a little more questions,
'cause it's more valuable.
- Cool, cool, so we have more.
- Okay.
- Please.
- [Mac] Hi, Gary, Mac.
- And we have to go to the back, right?
Like people at back, you
wanna ask a question, right?
(whoop)
- Just raise your hand.
- [Mac] Hi, Gary, this is Mac.
I have a question, you
exactly Silicon Valley
and then values and the
businesses, people over there.
Hong Kong, Singapore, a
lot of places in China
want to kind of copy, this
kind of values, standards.
What they are, and how we can
learn from this place of that.
- So,
that would make me really sad if Asia
started replicating
Silicon Valley standards.
(cheering)
You know.
Well, first of all, if
you look at, for example,
the Chinese social network
ecosystem and platforms,
they, because of the payment integration,
have much better business models.
Silicon Valley, bless you, Silicon Valley
(chuckling)
Silicon Valley
VC, let me rephrase.
It's not Silicon Valley when
people say Silicon Valley,
what we're referring
to is venture capital.
The venture capital
model is very practical.
Stress all your companies
to be nonpractical
so that one gets through
and makes your fund return
on it's nonpracticality.
All that's happened in
the last seven years
of putting venture capital
business mindset to the forefront,
is we've taught a lot of
people to not be entrepreneurs.
We've taught a lot of
people of how to worship
fundraising, not business building.
The number one mistake Asia would make
is to follow the Silicon Valley blueprint.
That's it, man.
If you're talking about innovation,
like innovation will always matter,
but innovation happens all over the world.
Silicon Valley is just where kids go
after good shit happens.
Like, Facebook was invented in Boston.
Pinterest was invented in Pennsylvania.
This is that same bullshit
that universities trade on.
Silicon Valley trades on brand.
Harvard trades on brand.
These things are not as
valuable as we think.
We're worshiping the wrong thing.
So how can you improve on it,
what can you take out of it,
look, I think the entrepreneurial spirit
is very alive and well in Asia,
I think it's, unlike
other parts of the world,
it is a religion here,
just like it is in America,
so I think that's the cost
of entry, it's optimism.
It's where failure isn't
the deathblow in society,
it may hurt, but it's not a deathblow.
Really tough to fail at
an entrepreneurial venture
in Western Europe, really tough.
So I think that
spending any time, you know, even
my best advice for Asia
is to not pay attention
to America at all.
- Nother question, somewhere?
You have mic, right?
- [Shin] Hi, Gary, my name's Shin.
- Hi Shin.
- My question is
with so many opportunities
coming your way,
how do you decide the
people you want to work with
and collaborate with?
- Intuition.
(chuckling from audience)
(applause)
And Shin, to be honest with
you, what a shit answer, right?
Because it brings no value to anybody here
other than I just have
to tell you the truth.
It's, fuck.
It's what I go on, you know?
It's because I'm willing to fire fast.
People have their ego tied
up into hiring, it's insane.
Hiring is such a subtle thing.
Partnerships, hiring, and
investing, such a subtle thing.
People love to be romantic about
their judgment in character
thus, it deems them nonactionable
when it most matters.
Guys, humility is the game.
I've got plenty of bravado and peacocking,
I understand why it might
be hard to see my humility.
But humility is my strength.
I intuitively think that person's awesome,
I get to hang out with them for a week,
I realize they're an
idiot, I need to move.
Most people disguise it
so that people didn't think
they made the call wrong
in the first place.
- Cool, is there any other question?
- [Woman] I have a question.
- Okay.
- [Woman] Sorry, thank you so
much, Gary, for being here.
What is the one question
that no one is asking,
but that everyone should
be, in your opinion.
- God, this has been such a tough question
when it's come up.
(laughing)
It really is, this is one
of the toughest questions.
To really answer your question properly,
the question they should be asking
is the thing that they're
most scared to say out loud.
The question they should be asking is
hey, Gary, it's Shin here.
So my dad is insecure, and
thus, it's manifested in a way
where he's making me do this.
I love my dad, but I don't wanna do this.
And it's causing real
friction in my household.
And my mom is of a generation
that she blindly listens to my dad
and this feels very
toxic, what should I do?
That's the question,
and every other question
that looks like it, right?
The question that should be asked
is the one that nobody
wants to say out loud
because it exposes them.
- Over there, in the back.
- [Man] Hello, Gary.
- Hey.
- How are you?
- Very well.
- I'm from China.
- Good.
- Actually with
your Chinese translation team here.
So my question is about
the retail business.
- Retail.
- Yeah.
So for the past 10 days
there has been a article
in the WeChat, it's been reposted by
2,800 accounts and read
one hundred million times.
- Small numbers by China's standards.
- I'm kidding, go ahead.
- It's kinda big
on the WeChat though.
- Yeah, go ahead.
- By the way, I really wish
it was one of your articles,
we'll see, okay.
It's about the new supermarket
that has recently opened,
there's no human being on it.
- [Gary] There's no human beings in it?
- Yeah, you just went in
and grab the bread out
and went out and the payment
would be deducted from your
already paid account.
- Phenomenal.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I can literally not wait
for the robots to kill all of us.
(laughing)
- Okay, okay.
Sounds good.
So,
the online giants are
going back to offline.
The similar case would be
Amazon opened their first
physical store back in 2015 in Seattle
and a few weeks ago, Amazon
just bought Whole Foods, yeah.
So the giants, the online giants,
they have all the money
and resources to do that.
- That's good.
- Yeah, it's good, my question is...
- You know how this all plays out, right?
- Yeah.
- You know, consolidation
and then fragmentation,
consolidation and then fragmentation.
- So it's going to be the next generation
of retail business?
- Of course.
- My man, what always happens
in the history of time,
of capitalism, is once in a generation,
entrepreneurs come and
gobble up the landscape
and become the legendary
figures of their generation.
And then they either get fat and slow
and young companies find angles within it,
or they die and then different people come
and run the company that suck.
But like,
these are just cycles.
We had a new frontier, it
was called the internet.
It changed everything.
It's still very young.
Pioneers landgrabbed
the same way that people
bought up property thousands of years ago,
hundreds of years ago, right?
And the Mas and the Bezoses,
they become these iconic people
then they either die, or
stop running the companies.
And then youngsters
see the vulnerabilities
in the new thing.
Do you understand that in 20 years,
there'll be virtual reality and then
every piece of infrastructure
in our physical and internet
world will become vulnerable
and there'll be new people that landgrab
and the new Mas and the Bezoses, Karen Ma
is gonna start a virtual
world where she owns
all of the retail world,
because everything now becomes
virtual, because that's how we communicate
in an augmented world and so, cool.
Great, I'm glad I don't have
to take out my fuckin' wallet
going to fucking the store.
- Yeah, totally.
- So what's the question?
(laughing)
So, as the change is coming,
what's the potential
strain and opportunity
for the individual online retailers?
- The littler ones?
- The individual, like
you encourage people to
stay out of things on Ebay,
so there's a lot of...
- There's unlimited.
My man, how much do you
think Amazon and Alibaba
and everybody else, what
percentage of every transaction
in the world do you think
they'll ultimately own?
- [Man] I have no fucking idea.
- No problem.
(laughing)
Let me give you an answer,
not enough to allow trillions of people
to make tons of money.
- [Man] Yeah, sure, makes sense.
- The end.
- Thanks.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
- I guess, we have really,
we have time for one
more and then we need to move on.
Because you have other meetings.
- Okay.
- So one more, guys.
- Hi, Gary, I'm Mint from (inaudible)
and I have a question,
it's like the question you just mentioned.
I'm a young entrepreneur,
but I'm now in a stage
that I want to catch every
opportunity in front of me
and everything's important,
everything has a big benefit
to my life, so do you
have any suggestions of
how I choose this thing, 'cause every day
I sleep only four hours
to solve everything
that's really a problem.
- I think the answer is
to not judge yourself.
- Not judge myself?
- That's right.
So you're deploying 20
hours of taking advantage
of all these opportunities, right?
- Yeah.
- The reason you asked me
that question, is you're laying a bed
right before you go to
sleep for your four hours
and you're questioning yourself
if you did the right things
with those 20 hours,
instead of the other things
you could've done, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- So you're judging yourself.
- Okay.
- So the punchline
to that question and answer is this,
you will never be able to do everything.
You're such a fortunate young woman,
you're crippled by opportunity.
So just do as much shit as
you can in your 20 hours,
and then wake up the next
morning and do it again,
but never think about it ever again.
- [Woman] Okay, sure, thanks.
(cheering)
- So, 10 seconds, 10
seconds, 10 second question
you have over there, you were, yeah.
- Yes, awesome.
- [Adrian] I dunno if this is
gonna be quick, I'm Adrian.
- Hi, Adrian.
- Hi, Gary.
So taking a slightly different turn,
with all the entrepreneurial
stuff that you do,
what's the biggest tip
you have with dealing
with your wife and what
do you not compromise on
with your kids?
- So two things, with my wife,
and with any relationship you have,
you first have to make yourself happy.
Because if you're not happy,
you have vulnerability
to the entire ecosystem.
So
this is something that is
super politically incorrect.
This is not the answer that
most people hear or want,
but I'm selfish which
allows me to be selfless.
How do I handle it with my wife?
I overcommunicate with
her and keep checking in
and we talk about it all the time
as our lives evolve,
what is nonnegotiable.
What is, what isn't?
I, in the last three, four years
am spending more time
with my family not less.
It doesn't feel that
way because of the way
I'm doing content and distribution.
But I am, and then it's compounded,
because one of the lines in the sand
is we don't show our family to the world.
So you don't see content about my two kids
or my wife ever.
The most searched term
besides me, Gary Vaynerchuk,
is Gary Vaynerchuk
wife, because, you know.
Followed very closely by
Gary Vaynerchuk net worth.
(laughing)
So I just communicate, and
my hope is that I create
a framework that makes
her feel comfortable
to communicate things, too.
That she wants to say that
I may not wanna hear, right?
The nonnegotiable things with my kids,
is if I am in New York City
and they have a function,
I will not miss it.
So there is no meeting, there's
no CEO, no famous person,
no business opportunity that will trump
a recital or a play if
I'm in New York, but
I miss things all the time,
'cause I'm not in New York.
And I don't judge myself.
So I do the best I can and
I think the political
correctness of parenting
and work-life balance right
now is a very hot topic,
and I try not to talk about it too much,
because we all have
different relationships
and different situations.
Nobody knows what's going on in my bedroom
and I don't know what's going on in yours.
I think it's about communication
with the only people that matter.
You can judge my work-life
balance from afar,
I just don't give a fuck.
But I really care what
my wife thinks, right?
Communication.
- Awesome.
We don't have enough time.
- Thank you guys.
- We could be jamming
for like 15 hours.
So before we go, guys,
if you have the books,
those who have bought books,
please line up over there at the table
and we are gonna do some book signing.
But before, we sold some
tickets for this event,
but what are we gonna do with the money,
we're actually gonna give
it to Pencils of Promise.
- That's awesome.
- So I just wanted
to mention it because I
was in touch with them
and they said that you are
gonna be very happy about that.
- Thank you.
- And
Can we take a picture, Derek?
Are you around, because
I have something for you.
Because this is the first time
in Hong Kong and I want
you to remember it.
So we have a tee shirt, Gary
Vee hustling in Hong Kong 2017.
- I love it, thank you.
- And Drock,
can you come here as well?
We have something for you as well,
because you're also a hustler.
So we have a tee shirt for Drock as well.
(whoop)
Can we take a pic?
- Hope you guys got value out of that.
Would love for you to help
me clip some Instagram clips
so put timestamps in the comments
of the one minute clip that I should use
that's a new insight or
fire that you enjoyed.
See ya.
(light electro music)